hi guys i'm so excited to have
lindy bodes today lindy is a fantastic
polygate for those
the few of you left who don't know lindy
and she's been an inspiration i've been
watching her videos for two years
so i can't wait to talk to her and
to answer your questions lindy how's it
going
hi my god it's going really well uh we
are quite a time difference away so it's
uh
getting dark here but yeah it's been a
great day thanks thanks for having me
fantastic you uh you're ready to delve
into the questions
fantastic so without further ado let's
get started we
i'm going to select a few questions
you've asked us a deluge of questions we
put this
some time ago and we're gonna we have
selected the top we decided to answer
the top 10 questions and adrian
asks i can't wait how to balance working
full-time
and starting that was our comment so
lindy i know that you're very busy you
do a bunch of things how can you
actually learn so many languages and at
the same time have a full-time job and
on top of that
you know you're a super cool youtuber
how do you
how do you make the whole thing happen
thank you
um i think at first i need to realize
that i
i need to not be idealistic with my
language learning
i i'm never going to be able to reach
very high
levels in languages very fast because i
have to put my job first i have to
also maintain a youtube channel a blog
and so forth so i guess the first thing
is just
telling myself that um i shouldn't
think that i'm gonna progress fast um
and and just make peace with the fact
that things are gonna be slower
and then just trying uh to fit in and
have a
schedule and a system that works so i
always book italki lessons for myself i
have about two to three language lessons
in the evenings on weekdays and then
saturdays
and sundays is when i do the bulk of my
language study so usually on sunday
mornings
i will have brunch with my french friend
and we will get some french practice in
as well as a language study time
where i might be reviewing my notes for
my italki lessons
and throughout the week um because of
the nature of my job as a designer i can
listen to a lot of podcasts and listen
to language lessons because i'm
you know designing not really writing so
i do manage to fit in a lot of
auditory learning while i'm working as
well
fantastic as far as i'm concerned i
would my piece of advice would be
if you have a full full-time job
is to carve out a time slot
where your energy is kind of you know
acceptable or even
high so that you can learn every single
day now
you don't have to learn every single day
but if you learn regularly
it's better because you remember things
better for a number of reasons and
we all know life gets in the way right
so just to give you an idea of how i do
things i'm also
quite busy i'm you know trying to
grapple with
i have to grapple with a lot of things
in my life but
one fixed thing that i do is to learn
languages first thing in the morning so
i always
make sure that i wake up early because i
am what they call an early bird or
lark lion according to the last book i
read at power of when
when to do stuff and basically for one
hour
that is time that i dedicate to active
language learning so in your case
if you have a full-time job say from 9
00 am till
5 pm if you are a lion or you're an
early person maybe you want to carve out
30 minutes of a time of waking up
earlier
so that you you do this first thing in
the morning and then you don't have to
think about it anymore if you're like a
nine owl you can spend time in general
learning
languages at night when your energy is
higher we all have a different
chronotype
and the prototype defines or should
define how we do things and if you're
there's a misalignment between what you
do and the way your body
the the way the energy fluctuates along
the day
then you might have a problem so it's
possible to learn languages every day
you have to plan beforehand lindy was
saying that she has
she has it planned beforehand she
already knows during the week i'm gonna
have this
kind of conversation like conversation
on skype at this time that i'm gonna
have this time
so she crafted i i guess lindy and um
what you do similar from what i do is
that you organize beforehand you know
exactly what kind of activities when
and how and they are compatible with the
kind of work that you have so
in a nutshell i would say sit down plan
your time
you always we always have time to do we
always create time for the things
we like and language learning should be
no exception so if you want to learn
language learning
craft 20 minutes 30 minutes of your time
take a look
at the way you spend your week and the
way your energy
fluctuates during the day because it
depends on your prototype
and then just make it happen so um
so this is this was a very interesting
question
now on to the next one sarah from
facebook
asks would you say that we can apply the
same learning method
for any language um
this is something that we have touched
upon in another video that i
made with lindy so make sure to check in
the description box and also
in the comment section because uh
there's a link we have talked about
we've touched upon a lot of interesting
things that we touched
briefly touched upon this as well but
lindy
i wanted to ask you do you have
some does your method do you have a
fixed
path towards language learning towards
every single language you learn
when you learn from scratch and do you
think that
the structure or the idiosyncrasies or
some
features of certain languages kind of
dictate
or make you tweak
the method or the methodology that you
have already
adopted for in general for learning
languages
yeah great question um i think for my
languages i have a general timeline or
mindset that i use
um for every language so knowing that i
need to start with
the basic greetings and then the
sentence structure and filling in
kind of having one sentence structure
that i say for instance i like
a verb and then i like verb with someone
and i like verb with someone in place so
i create these little sentences for
myself
at the very beginning of a language so
in terms of knowing what i want to learn
by when
my structure is the same but like you
said the idiosyncrasies or the grammar
of the language does dictate
a different approach especially the word
order
uh so it's a lot easier for me to to
understand languages that are similar to
languages i've
learned otherwise whereas with hungarian
for instance that has quite a flexible
word order
it might give i might require a lot more
time to understand the complex grammar
and the word order of that so
it means that the there's no cookie
cutter technique because it depends on a
lot of factors
as well if you're learning a language
that has a different writing system for
instance mandarin chinese you're going
to have to dedicate if you want
a lot of time to learning how to read
and write these characters it's not just
an alphabet you can learn once
and then you can read even if you don't
know the meaning if you don't know how
to read it and you don't know the
meaning
so definitely a different approach
according to the script of the language
and the grammar if you already
understand the sentence structure and
the grammar there's no need to
dedicate a lot of time reviewing grammar
notes when you already understand it
so it depends on how difficult the
language is
and how similar it is to languages
you've learned before
excellent answer as far as i'm concerned
i always have more or less the same path
always have the same technique that i
use like the biodirectional translation
technique
where i use my own native language i
translate back and forth in order to
understand the structure
of of the target language but the
reality is that as lindy was saying
there are so many
different features to different
languages so
sometimes doing something that works
really well with one language might not
yield the same results in another just
to give you an idea
and i talked about this in in the video
with lindy is that
when i was learning um japanese i
realized that the bi-directional
translation
was not exactly the perfect fit and
using translation
for languages that have a different
syntax might actually backfire get in
the way
and i realized this a little bit later
down the line so i might have used a
different approach
and for languages like portuguese you
can use the by director and translation
to understand the patterns but the
reality is that the language portuguese
in and of itself is already similar to
italian
it's very similar to languages i already
had under my belt and in that case
i might want to use a different strategy
meaning speaking almost
from day one from the get-go because you
will realize
when you speak that actually you can do
it much faster than you thought because
your brain does not have the burden of
a different syntax morphology like the
form of words or the way you arrange
words
to convey meaning it's so similar that
you can
actually start from the very beginning
so i would say
get in general having a methodology that
applies the bulk of this methodology
that applies to
languages is okay meaning having knowing
what you
how to start a language from scratch but
then you should
be flexible enough to understand that
different languages have different
features and challenges
and you can tweak what you have so that
you can learn more efficiently the
language
uh you know the target language at hand
and to the next question always from
facebook by
orai the top three most common mistakes
to avoid for someone
willing to become a polyglot
this is an interesting one i think this
depends on
what angle we want to answer the
question from if it is language learning
technique wise or if it's mindset wise
i'm going to answer the question
based on the last part they said of
someone who wants to be a polygon not
necessarily someone who wants to learn a
language
i'm going to start and it might be a
little controversial is
don't aim to be a polygon your goal is
not to be able to say
i can speak x amount of languages that
is it's quite harmful because
what are you really doing it for what is
the goal the goal is i want to speak x
amount of languages it's not i'm
learning this language for this reason i
have a friend who speaks this language i
want to learn how to communicate
it's just numbers it's a numbers game
and i think that that's a very toxic
mindset because you end up comparing
yourself to people
like this person speaks 12 languages i
only speak five
and it's just not healthy so i think um
number one mistake is
uh your your motivation and choosing
being a polyglot as a goal i never
really thought
um my goal is to be a polygon it's just
that
after learning multiple languages there
just so happened to be a word
that is a polyglot to describe someone
who speaks multiple languages it's never
been like hey i want to be a polyglot
let me start so
i guess just considering your motives
your motivations
is what i would say is one small mistake
another thing kind of ties into that is
comparing yourself to people
um everybody has a backstory everyone
has problems
everyone has a different way of learning
a language as well as different times
resources so if you're thinking this
person was able to reach fluent japanese
in two years
and i've been struggling for 10 years
it's not helpful you're wasting your
time
comparing yourself to someone when you
could be using that time study
and the last thing i think is not
worrying so
much about the resources or having the
exact proper way to learn a language
everybody learns differently you may be
able to afford or not afford resources
there might be resources available in
your country that aren't available in
other countries
people are so caught up in trying to
find the perfect textbook the perfect
method
and the perfect way to learn a language
and that is slowing down the time it
takes for them to just start and learn
the language i think it's great to start
anywhere
if you have um like noodles in your
cupboard and at the back of the noodle
packet there is something written in
another language that
that's something that's something you
can hold on to and maybe start and learn
how to translate that you don't need to
wait
for the most expensive best textbook to
arrive you need to create your own
opportunities to learn a language
right on the money again fantastic
fantastic answer this is from the point
of view of the mindset i would say
that it's really important because
people throw this polygon word around as
if it were like some kind of prize it's
not it's just a way of living
it doesn't change you as a person if you
have polygam written here
on your forearm that it doesn't it
doesn't change anything
um this is the first thing the second
thing i would say in general that
one common mistake is to try to learn a
lot of languages at the same time for
the sake of
adding up numbers so you can go around
and say i can speak 15 languages or 16
languages the thing you were saying
before
i think you should learn one language
well to fluency
to start using it in real life because
that's where the real
language magic happens so to speak and
then you can learn other languages this
is
if you want to learn two or three if you
have enough time and energy go by all
means go for it but i would say that
most people
do not have the time the energy and the
mental resources to learn two three
four languages at the same time at the
end of the day it doesn't really matter
the second thing is to focus one common
mistake of language learners not only
for those who want to become followers
is to focus
on goals instead of systems they ask a
lot of my students
ask all the time when are we going to be
fluent in the language when is this
going to happen
it's like you know the donkey and trek
like are we there yet
you know this this annoying donkey asked
me all the time are we there yet
which is a matter for for you know
nowadays people ubiquitous impatience of
wanting to get there as soon as possible
language learning unfortunately
is not the kind of thing that you can
just accomplish
you know you can reach fluency in a
matter of two or three weeks it's
something that requires time
effort and ears so instead of focusing
on goals
because this backfires once again if
you're constantly asking yourself
whether you have reached
fluency or not then you know after two
weeks and you realize that you haven't
reached fluency yet this can be
discouraging instead focus
on systems we're saying before lindy has
developed tweaked as much as i have a
system
which allows her to learn on a daily
basis you know all
even if she has a lot of you know stuff
uh to deal with um and um i would say
that the third thing is that
another important thing to keep in mind
is that i think you should focus
on um on you should avoid spending too
much time on books meaning books are
great
resources are great that's fantastic but
the reality is
that language learning and when it comes
to speaking a language
really well it's about living it's not
just about reading and listening to
language learning material sooner or
later you will have to venture
into real life and that's where the
magic of language learning happens
that's where you're going to have
experiences in a foreign language that's
where we're going to speak with people
when you're going to share
emotions where you're going to share
happy and sad moments
so in my case especially when it comes
to
uh speaking a lot of languages polyglot
right like
a polyglot is a person as a multilingual
person who can
juggle who can manage multiple languages
if you do not make languages a part of
your life
if you do not use languages on a daily
basis or
some of the languages under your belt
you're going to find it extremely
difficult to catch up because
the amount of languages are going to
pile up and if you have these languages
just like either subjects that you're
going to touch upon and
and study or it's still kind of a
bookish
routine then imagine having 10 languages
where you have to spend 30 minutes on
each book it becomes a nightmare
so you want to design a life where you
use these languages
i think lindy for you it's the same
right you you use
some of the languages that you have on a
daily basis
so that's that's why i think it's really
important to not just focus on books
let's move on to the next question um we
could be speaking for hours but
we we we're trying to make it you know
concise and nice for you guys
uh a g ajg
i think i pronounced it correctly i hope
from also from facebook most politics
suggest learning
only one language at a time to max but
lindy seems to be learning multiple
languages at once
i'd be really interested to hear you
guys discuss this topic at length
and ask lindy how she handles learning
multiple languages at the same time
you cannot unfortunately discuss it at
length but i'm pretty sure that leni can
give a concise answer
to show you how she learns multiple
languages over the course of a week
yeah um i think people
often interpret polygon as someone who
is learning
multiple languages all at once from the
same level like
beginner you're starting 12 languages
and you're learning them all absolutely
not
i started with english was my first
foreign language actually
then i slowly learned french at school
and then arabic became a school subject
and only in like my grade 10 year of
high school i started learning korean
it's been 10 years for korean halfway
through korean i started learning
japanese
halfway through learning japanese it was
chinese and thereafter
little things like vietnamese spanish
hungarian and tagalog came along so it
has been
like 20-ish years of language learning
where i'm slowly building up languages
on each other
none of my languages are completely
beginner starting at the same time it's
always a little bit like
stacking and focusing maybe years or
months on one language before i learn
another language it's really a lifelong
thing
i think people who kind of become
interested in the polyglot world they
they might be starting at one or two
languages and their goal is to become a
polyglot and you think you need to learn
all these languages at once but you
don't realize that
um you need to slow down a little and
consider how many years
and how many months it takes really to
to learn the language
um the other thing that you were
mentioning is kind of like the system i
have so i choose
maybe one or two focused languages for a
set period of months
or weeks and then i um integrated into
my day so i might do
a vietnamese and hungarian lessons twice
a week for three months and then for the
next set of three months i might be
focusing on
another language so it's really just
prioritizing and
none of my languages really are starting
from zero at the same time
fantastic answer as far as i'm concerned
that's i think that's more or less like
in linda's case meaning i've been
stacking languages i've been learning
one language at a time for multiple
years i started
learning english and french at school
when i was when i was 10
and then since i started learning my
first foreign language by myself
which is german at the ripe age of 15
i've been learning more or less a
language
every two years so i learned a language
i spend my time i was focusing on that
one language and then i moved on to
learn
another language but i made sure that i
kind of reached a certain level before i
moved on i think that you can learn
multiple languages at the same time but
the more languages you learn
the less energy you can energy time
focus you can dedicate to each and every
language
in my case recently over the last i
would say
10 years i've been trying to learn
two languages at the same time sometimes
one
for example right now i've been learning
greek
hungarian and danish but i've just
realized that three languages is too
much so
i had to make a choice and right now i'm
focusing mainly
on greek and um hungarian i have two
different systems again i have
system one is the art is the group of
languages i can speak fluently
and i have designed a system so that i
can use
six to eight languages on a daily basis
for different reasons
but that doesn't require much of you
know a lot of energy because these are
languages i know
well and i'm using in real life and then
generally
i have two focused languages or two
languages that i
um require deliberate practice me
sitting down
and you know doing all sorts of
activities so time and focus
and normally i never try to learn more
than two languages
the three language experiment was an
exception so my piece of advice would be
if you can't learn just one language to
fluency it might take a couple of years
if you do things well and then you can
move on to next language
sometimes when you learn a language that
is similar to the one you've just
learned or one of the languages under
your belt
it's going to be easier so patience one
thing at a time you know it's a long
term process as lindy says it's for me
it's been 30 years
just because i'm a little bit older than
lindy but
you know it's been we have been learning
languages for years and decades i would
say
just you count language running in
decades um
anna tamani i uh
i think it's from um
instagram listen to music is a good way
to practice a language
how could we practice a language if we
are
introvert that's that's if we are
introverts
thank you that's our answer lindy are
you an introvert an extrovert or
does it really matter i am very much an
introvert
uh most definitely and actually i think
language learning has made me a little
bit more extroverted
in the sense that i realize i'm never
going to be able to advance in this
language if i'm not speaking
i'm never going to be able to speak if i
don't put myself out there
and talk to people so i actually have i
don't mean to promote my own channel
here but i have two very in-depth videos
about
learning languages as an introvert so
i'm not going to go into detail now
because everything i can say on the
topic is on my channel
but essentially you just kind of have to
rip the band-aid off if it is your goal
to speak
you have to go out there find a safe
space find a like a language learning
group maybe it's just one person you
trust
maybe it's starting with a tutor until
you build the confidence and realize
if your goal is really to speak um you
have to put yourself out there
if it's not your goal to speak there are
multiple other ways to enjoy language
learning whether it's just
watching movies journaling listening to
music
and enjoying the language without having
to directly interact
with people i guess just touching on the
first question there with music is it a
good way to practice a language
no because you're not practicing the
language you are just listening to it so
it's a good way to get listening
exposure
it's a good way maybe to learn new
vocabulary if you are actively engaging
it
uh luca and i just did a video for my
channel where he mentioned that
someone was listening to chinese
television for 10 000 hours and they
could not speak the language
um by the end of that because you're
just possibly listening you are not
actively engaging with the content so
listening to music is a good way to
practice the language if you are
writing down the lyrics looking up the
words practicing how to say it
and so forth fantastic
now um to complete the question all the
information that
lindy has given you which which i find
uh really amazing
is i would say as far as music is
concerned i would use it on top of other
things so
if you want to practice the language the
bulk of your time you you should be
practicing the language you'll be
speaking the language because
that's a direct way of honing your
skills
but this does not mean that you should
not listen to music and if you want to
listen to music you find
for example some lyrics you sing along
that's great but this should be on top
of other things the core activity of you
know regarding speaking if you want to
speaking if you want to speak slash
practice language
should be speak slash practice the
language
and um here the answer the question i
hope the rest of the question how we
could
prac how can we practice a language if
we're an introvert
i would say that um regardless of
intro like i think this is
maybe not a label there are people who
are more um you know
extroverse than introverts i would say
my case for example i don't really know
if i'm
an extrovert an introvert in my life i
found my i
sometimes i'm an introvert sometimes an
extrovert sometimes i feel like talking
for hours sometimes
i'm a little bit you know it's more
difficult it depends on the
circumstances in school i was definitely
not an extrovert i was spending most of
the bulk of my time by myself
and then everything changed so i think
that
language learning and life in general
can actually
shape and mold your personality and
and that's that's one thing the second
thing is that whether you're in
an introvert or not whether you're an
introvert or not
speaking a foreign language is going to
be challenging no matter what happens
the first if when the first time comes
that you have to speak a language with a
native speaker no matter where you are
either skype or real life it's going to
be a little bit intimidating
because it's you know the art of
practicing
the the unknown of finding yourself in
an unknown
situation with a stranger that in and of
itself human beings biologically are a
little bit scared of that so
but one thing i would say one piece of
advice is like
one thing that you can do is instead of
getting out there and speaking direct
with people which can be a little bit
too
intimidating and challenging especially
if you're an introvert why don't you
just take a step
back and take many steps towards that
goal just an example of starting
practicing
simple sentences by yourself or
imagining situations where you're going
to interact with someone
introducing yourself even if you do it
by yourself
still you're getting some phrases and
sentences a little bit automatic
remember you will get stuck
a little bit at the beginning because
your limbic system is going to get in
the way
and then you can practice with someone
on skype you know you find someone who's
a very nice person
there are a lot of nice pers people out
there you can find
and then you start practicing little by
little so that you reduce the impact
of getting out there and speaking the
language because the reality is it's
it's challenging
and i myself even after learning i don't
know how many languages
after when i learn a new language it's
always a little bit
you know i'm always hesitant because i
want to
get things right but you will get things
wrong no matter what happens
what happens and that's the beauty of
getting out there and speaking a foreign
language is about growth it's about
growing as a person
as a learner as an individual as a
citizen of the world
um mauricio fermin uh
kolker i think how can you organize the
time for
learning and keeping languages um
we've talked about that we've talked
about
you know learning and and keeping
languages just let me say
this before before you speak lindy that
in my case
one of the things that is really
important when it comes to managing
multiple languages at the same time as i
said before
is that when you learn new languages at
least in my case i don't know about
lindy but i always make sure
that every language that i add i take
care
of the other sisters and brothers i call
them it's like having a family like you
have a newborn
and when when um a new baby is born the
other one
the other ones are a little bit jealous
because you you give all the focus all
the focus and the attention and the care
this new language needs but don't don't
forget the brothers and sisters
so make sure that if you have say three
languages under your belt
somehow if that is important for you
just find
a way to practice them either i don't
know you can just
listen to uh the news in russian if you
already speak russian
and do something in spanish use these
languages that you already know
uh find creative ways to integrate them
into your life
and then you can um you know you can
learn the new
the new one because that's important but
just to
answer to finish the the answer i always
have a system
where no matter what happens i carve out
a time
every day to learn actively at least
one new language especially in the
morning when i feel
energized and ready to go and then i
design the system
to keep my other languages alive by
using them
and on a final note it's impossible to
keep up with every single language you
have
every single day something's got to give
sooner or later
i can't one thing that i uh i feel like
it's a it's an important recommendation
do not get obsessed
by language learning languages are live
creatures you use to make your life
better they're not
stuff that you're constantly oh i have
to do russian and swedish so now
10 minutes of swedish otherwise you run
the risk of um
you know of when languages take over
that's problematic to say the least so
celine said relax you know languages are
great things to learn
but we are humans we're limited in space
and time what do you think lindy
absolutely i i like what you said about
kind of
when you're feeling very active in the
mornings when you do your new language
study and that ties in quite nicely to
energy management and i like to
re-evaluate how i'm spending my time
with the language so a big mistake i
realized this year
2020 is not to plan for the whole year
because
when i wanted to learn burmese in
january by december i did not feel like
it anymore so i try to re-evaluate every
few weeks or months
about which languages i want to be
learning and also evaluate my energy
levels knowing that i am a night owl or
i just don't want to wake up early in
the morning
so instead of telling myself i have to
wake up at 5 00 a.m and study two
chapters
i really check in with my energy levels
because you might have
seven hours in a day to study a language
but you might only have two hours where
your brain
is active enough to focus fantastic and
then
one one i wanted to add to that
when people ask me how can i become a
language learner an efficient language
and i always say
one of the first things you have to
think about is how you manage your life
first not just
language learning people want to learn a
bunch of languages but maybe they
are um they have problems at school or
they're constantly
uh preoccupied and worried about stuff
there was a comment on youtube recently
said how can i learn languages how can i
find focus if i'm constantly worried
about what happens in my life and i say
well
but take good care of that first and
then maybe you will find the time the
energy and the focus to learn languages
because
if you're constantly worried about
something else either you can't make
ends meet or
you have other problems with other
things then language learning
is not gonna get easier because it
requires time
effort and and discipline so i always
say
one thing that i've learned recently at
the ripe age of 40
is that the very first thing that you
know language learning is important but
i think that first and foremost your
mental sanity
and your health are the most important
things you have
seems trivial but it's not and also your
focus
so regain focus of your life regain
concentration
take care of what you eat how you sleep
how you live because that's going to
have a huge
impact on language learning wanting to
improve your language learning without
improving
or focusing on those things is not
going to help you know it's it's not
gonna cut it as they say let me see
there's another question
by uh nathan i think by an on instagram
this kind of touches upon stuff we
already talked about but
uh we can maybe um face it and tackle it
from another angle
how do you move on to learn learning new
languages if you feel like you haven't
perfected the ones you started to learn
i've learned german and spanish for
seven years but have been stuck at the
intermediate level in these languages
i'm not sure how you continue to improve
them while starting to learn another
language but i really want to learn
more languages any suggestion so i guess
that what he's asking is
how do you move from when you get stuck
which is inevitable
inevitable how do you move from say
intermediate level to a higher level how
how did you make it happen in
some of the languages you speak so
nathan
first of all getting stuck is something
extremely
normal because that's how the human body
this is how the human
body and mind work um when you get to a
certain level
the body your body and mind readjust and
then you have to do something
else something more challenging to get
out of the rut as they say so
this happens for example when you start
running for 30 minutes
then if you do this for say six months
then
you don't see the effects because you
start you should start writing 35
minutes
45 minutes or you should tweak the way
you run maybe you
have to run a little bit faster same
thing for language learning if you learn
a language
at the beginning strategies for starting
a language work
great but then you get stuck it means
that probably
you're doing the same thing over and
over you have to remember that your
language learning skills as any other
skills be it motor skills or cognitive
skills such as language learning
they grow with time
and when they grow with time some things
that you find
cool and interesting and challenging at
the very beginning
might not be so anymore so in my case
i do this by direction and translation
to
start a language from scratch it works
super cool so super well at the very
beginning i'm super excited
but would not dream honestly of using
this
at the intermediate level because once i
reach the intermediate level i want to
speak
i want to talk to people i want to use
longer
pieces of content like podcast instead
of focusing on small
small pieces of content and translating
back and forth
so in a nutshell my answer is if you
want to move
from one stage to the other you have to
design a learning system
that encompasses some of the things
you're doing
but you have to integrate some other
things that
need to be enjoyable and challenging so
something that was
um you know something that is not
challenging anymore because things
have become too easy and you're doing
the same thing
you have to tweak it either the length
of content
you know or on the the difficulty of the
content nowadays you can find multiple
platforms where you can choose the level
or maybe you're speaking always about
the same things hi my name is
or stuff you know it's time to delve
into
unknown ground any sort of growth
entails
some sort of discomfort but the
discomfort
has to be within what they call the
goldilocks so
not too difficult not too easy the sweet
spot is where you find something that
either in reading listening writing or
speaking
something that is not too
so it's not easy because it's otherwise
it would be boring but it's not too
difficult as to be discouraging if you
constantly find a sweet spot and adapt
it with time
bingo then you're gonna you're gonna
keep improving and
and growing yeah absolutely i think
it's important what you say once you get
to the intermediate plateau you need to
change up your methods
because your level is not the same so
your methods should not be the same and
that helps keep things interesting as
well so i'm going to answer in a way
that
is uh not not maybe what this person is
looking for and i think language
learning is such a personal journey and
this person needs to consider what are
their goals for each language so the the
two languages that they're focusing
that they uh kind of hit a plateau at
now what is their goal do they want to
be able to progress in this
in future or do they just want to be a
polygon and learn x amount of languages
now are they willing to sacrifice
progress
in those two languages so that they can
learn another language and enjoy
speaking three languages to some level
or are they really committed to seeing a
future with those two languages so i
think just
looking inside yourself and questioning
how important are these languages really
to me do i need to stop learning new
ones so that i can focus on these
uh using the methods that luca just
pointed out changing up your methods um
finding that sweet spot
or are you willing to say ah it's okay
to kind of leave them at the
intermediate
plateau because deep in my heart i'm
really so excited to learn a new
language so i'm gonna pause on those
it's okay if my
level uh goes down a little bit because
right now what i really want is to
explore a new language so um check your
check your goals and check your um
your motifs your motivation for for
learning languages
i think lindy said it all so i don't
need to answer the second part of this
question because i fully agree with her
let's move on to the next question this
question has been asked has been written
in italian so i'm going to read it in
italian i know that
lindy i don't think you speak a time but
maybe you can understand it through
spanish but regardless of that
i'm going to read it in italian and i'm
going to translate it into
english and then if you want to
i don't know if you want to use another
language i don't know
lindy or you can just if you don't want
to just answer in english
so i had this idea because i thought it
would be just in english but then you
surprised me with the multilingual stuff
so
it's totally up to you francisco asks
little q a
how was your first chat in a foreign
language like
um and how to unblock
how to face this block because i guess
that a lot of people
fear the first very first conversation
in a foreign language so
lindy how how did you address that how
was your first conversation in korean or
in japanese or any other language
yeah it's different for each language uh
for me for korean it was
very very very stressful i just wanted
to say hello to someone um they were the
shop owner of a korean shop all i wanted
to do was say onyaseo and i was like
trembling i was quivering
it's because i put so much like emphasis
on this big moment
that it was it was just awkward and um i
was very nervous
whereas the more languages i learned the
more comfortable i become with the idea
of um
speaking to strangers and speaking in a
language that i'm not confident in
so my first spanish conversation was
obviously i was making a ton of mistakes
but i was a lot more comfortable because
i knew
making mistakes is part of the process
sweden to the point um i would say
francesco
i think i've addressed this um in one of
the uh the questions before
or in the other on the other video so
you might want to check that out that i
did for
for lindy on our channel but i think
that one of the
things that you can do to face this
block is just to take small steps
whatever happens
you know when uh when you speak your
foreign language for the first time
you're going to get a little bit jittery
you're going to be a little bit
self-conscious it's inevitable because
of
our the way we are built our biology we
we fear the unknown and having a
conversation with a stranger on top of
that in another language
um is a little bit challenging in and of
itself that's the reason why i think
first you have to relax and and tell
yourself that this is going to be
a little bit of awkwardness um is
inevitable and the second thing is take
baby steps towards
that goal so start talking to yourself
start imagining situations
start thinking of ways in which you can
react
act and react imagine that when you have
a conversation it's not just the problem
of
getting your point across it's also what
happens if if this guy or this girl in
the shop
or wherever just asks you point blank
something you don't understand
so has i'm pretty sure lindy does has
happened to you as well right
like you get ready oh you're gonna focus
on on the speaking part and then all of
a sudden the point blank they ask you
stuff and you're like uh
and and for me i don't know about you
lindy but for me
some conversations even simple when i
speak the language
i i don't speak the language well yet
are easier
if they're longer on skype to have
context
then very brief conversations when
you're
where when you ask when you when you're
supposed to
complete a relatively easy task like i
don't know buy something or buy a ticket
and all of a sudden that person
i don't know you want to you want to get
a train ticket and she asked something
about the time this happened to me in
hungary for example
i felt i felt like an idiot you know
just like oh
i went there i just rehearsed some some
lines and then all of a sudden she asked
me stuff so
it's inevitable but imagine
uh yourself having this conversation
maybe you can foresee things happening
you can simulate conversations on skype
find a friendly person to talk to on
skype
be it a tandem be it a teacher it's easy
to find teachers nowadays
you can find tandems but it's more
difficult and nowadays teachers
are available on platforms like
italki or verbling there's a lot of them
and then practice
practice before you venture into unknown
ground because it's
inevitably going to be a little bit
challenging sometimes a little bit
awkward but that's the way we learn and
grow
so uh on to the last and final question
by
raffaluco on instagram
professors
so what he's asking basically is do you
use teachers
do you think the teachers are important
and if so how
do you interact with your tutor
tutors slash teachers
[Music]
or vietnamese
important
like i i feel like i will teach myself
the wrong things when i'm a beginner
and uh
or professor or they can like
they give me homework and they can
correct my sentences on the spot so i'm
not teaching myself the wrong thing
[Music]
no like there are people who don't know
um
[Music]
um i guess i'm just mixing my languages
here because i haven't touched spanish
for months but
there's uh why you're doing great yeah
there's a few people who community
tutors sometimes who just
they just chat to you and they don't
actually know how to teach a language so
if you have a teacher who actually knows
how to structure a lesson and teach
grammar it's a lot easier
than kind of just doing a language
exchange so i think teachers are
important to some extent when
you're very serious about the language
and when it's a difficult language that
you cannot really teach yourself
[Music]
um
you can speak french too my professor
[Music]
uh i'm sorry i spoke french the whole
day so i'm going to continue in french
if you don't mind
um
[Music]
hobbies there like there will always be
topics that for you to talk about um
it can be boring if you have nothing to
talk about which is why it's important
to have
a professional teacher who knows what
they're doing
rather than a language uh partner
who you have nothing in common
it's an interesting um it's an
interesting answer it's a little bit
different than
your your your my your vision uh
or your ideas about this is all slightly
different than mine
um let me address this in which language
should i address let's let me do spanish
first and then let me switch to french
because
you've done that um
[Music]
this is it um guys i hope
you liked the interview i uh it's always
interesting to talk to lindy who's got a
lot of interesting stuff
to say if you want to check her channel
uh lindy what's your channel can you
tell me
two or three things for our audience
where they can find your wonderful stuff
thank you yeah you can just search my
name it's lindy buettis
l-a-n-d-i-e-b-o-t-e-s
and everything about language learning
productivity
you can find that on my channel thanks
and we will put
all the links in the description box in
the comment section thanks a bunch
happy language learning and um thanks
for watching
bye lindy hi bye
you